Okay. Hello Andy. Hi, Mr Rogan. Thanks for having me. My pleasure.
How are you doing, man? You're all healed up.
The bruising and swelling has gone down.
As you can see about the most serious injury was to the brain.
You have a serious injury to your brain. Yeah. Brain hemorrhage.
What happened from what? The mall beating? So they were getting hit in the head.
You got a brain hemorrhage multiple times. Really? Intuitions. Yes,
they were bashing me on the back of my head and to my eyes.
But what,
so how do you know you had brain hemorrhaging and how are you able to just walk
around?
Well, I was taken to, I started losing my balance after the beating.
There was no police. I made it to the Court House, sat down on the ground.
Ambulance was called.
I had to walk back to the ambulance because the streets were a walk back to the
police precinct in the direction of the mall.
The medics that were associated with the Portland police let me know that they,
um, that I needed to walk in that direction.
It was quite shocking because it was, um,
I had just been a victim of the small beating and then now they're telling me to
walk back in direction of, uh,
the central precinct where the beating had happened.
Did they not know that you had been beaten up? Well, let's, let's let, let's,
let's set this up for people who are new to this and don't understand what
happened. Um,
I'd been aware of you because of you had written for Colette,
right. And, uh,
you had become one of these for whatever reason,
controversial online journalists and uh,
you covered antifa quite a bit and you covered a lot of, uh,
the radical left. You were in Portland. And uh,
what was the exact rally that was going on? What was it called?
Does it have a name?
Uh, it was something like protect Portland.
So it was organized by roasted.
He on to fight and its allies and by its allies I meet,
I am referring to the local chapter of the Democratic Socialists of America that
came out to some book done in numbers.
And what are they protecting Portland from?
They allege a fascist fascist, but just in general,
I mean is there like a particular thing they're worried about?
There were two right wing events happening that day that they were counter
demonstrating against. There was a on one side and pod one pod are downtown.
The proud boys for holding a flag waving event that was completely a peaceful.
There was no actually flag waving American flag waving. Correct. Okay. Um,
and a lot of Portlanders found that provocative and a manifestation of a fish's
stick violence and, and another part of downtown,
there was a men's rights activists who was holding, um, a rally.
Uh, it was titled for, for victims of domestic terrorism.
It was an anti antifa event. So,
uh,
a men's rights activist yes.
That was doing an anti fascist or anti antifa.
Correct. Well, what boy,
it seems like a whole lot of do about nothing. Flag-Waving and anti anti.
Okay.
Yeah. Can I set the context for please? For the city of Portland? It's a mess.
You have listeners and viewers all over the world. So Portland,
Oregon is a extremely progressive city in the Pacific northwest of the u s and,
um, I call it a political monoculture because really it's, um, uh,
not just,
you're more likely to find Socialists Open Socialists there then you would find
like a regular, uh,
republican or Conservative and within the sort of echo chamber of just left us
politics, there's,
it's become also a hotbed for far left militancy Soro city Antifa is,
you could call it like the local chapter movement of Antifa is one of the oldest
in the country. It's very large in Portland. And they hold,
um, what you could call protests, but they're there.
Their protest would always devolve into riots where they essentially take over
parts of downtown and attack people,
attack their ideological opponents and do it frequently with impunity.
I mean, I wasn't the only one to talk that day.
There were two other people who were bashed on the head very and have very
severe lacerations to the face on hat. And you may recall the footage, uh,
from October of last year when there was an elderly driver who was attacked on
the streets.
Yeah, they were directing traffic. Exactly. And somehow or another,
the mayor thought it was a good idea to let this take place. Is that the case?
And they told the police to stand down. Is that true?
So, um,
I mean the next part of this journey for me will be the legal aspect of it.
And it seems like something things in Portland,
the issue is really not with the rank and file officers.
They're following orders to not intervene. So I,
I had been, uh,
assaulted and criminally harassed early before the mob, beating people,
throwing milkshakes at my face and head within eyesight of police who were
watching in downtown. And both of these were reported. And the,
the answer that I heard that day as I've heard many times before when I've been
assaulted by Antifa is that we will not question,
approach or detain the suspect because this couldn't, it's like the crowd.
Okay. So this is why this has exacerbated,
or this is why this has become such a big deal in Portland because of this
attitude.
Because Portland seems to be the hot bed right now for this kind of stuff.
Is that, is that fair to say? I think it is.
So is this the mayor hook mean who is,
who's the one who's giving the orders to the police to tell them to allow stuff
to take place?
Well, on,
on crowd funding for the legal fund right now and we are willing,
we are going to hold accountable.
Whoever is responsible for dereliction of duty where the evidence leads us.
So Portland has the odd Duvernay's system in that the mayor who is up for
reelection by the way, is also the police commissioner,
so, oh wow. Yeah. How does that work?
It, it was an old system that I had inherited and it just,
it never changed from the wild west. Like that sounds ridiculous.
It is ridiculous. You can see all the political con,
the conflicts and then conflicts of interest that that would arise. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. Shitload. Um, how did you get involved in this? Like what, why,
first of all, why were they angry you, I uh,
I work as a journalist. Uh,
I'll name like places that I've been published before.
I write and I do video and I do podcasts.
So my written work has been published in the Wall Street Journal,
the National Reviews Spectator,
New York Post and my on the editorial team of Collette magazine. Um,
and one of my beats among south row is about far less militancy,
particularly in Portland.
And to me what I was noticing was that the national and local media coverage had
a particular blind spot when it came to the coverage on Antifa.
There was all this sensitivity to the colonoscopy far-right and uh,
white nationalism or white identity extremism,
but they could not or would not recognize the militancy that was on the left.
And Portland's seem to be one of the places for Ground Zero,
particularly after 2016,
we had very violent rioting and downtown that, um,
a segment of the population could not accept the election results in November.
And so, uh, they did $1 million in damage setting fires and,
uh, destroying properties and businesses. And I thought time,
I was a graduate student working at the student paper and I did a story on that
and I came out to witness and it, it, you know, this was a major American city,
but it felt like I was in Afghanistan or Iraq just with all of these fires and
explosions and people running around with bouts while I messed up.
And that was the first time I really became familiar with Antifa and I took an
interest in it and I saw over and over that the media coverage was basically
really sorta whitewashing them,
kind of like referring to them as antifascist,
giving them that propaganda victory and anti Pfizer movement,
the monsters of doublespeak and disinformation.
So it starts with name. Antifa is short for antifascists,
but I never refer to them as [inaudible] because, um,
that's seeding the ground to, uh, to them.
Uh, they, when they say that they are, uh,
defending a community self-defense,
it actually is referring to meet premeditated violence and offensive violence.
So I started going into covering this more and more. You know,
after I left the student paper, I started writing for, um,
some national and international publications.
And there internationally there was, uh, you know,
a set of readers who interested in what the hell is going on in Portland,
why are there these continuous scenes of street brawls and anarchy over and
over? What are the variables that are causing this?
And I thought that I could try to shine a light on it.
And by doing so,
Antifa became enraged with my work and particularly things they've hated me
since last year. But they started really escalating,
um, on, on the 1st of May, May Day. Um,
so this year was when I was physically assaulted by them for the first time.
They were very upset that I wrote a story for the New York Post where there was
a series of,
and this is one of the other beats that I work on is a hate crime hoaxes.
Um, Portland earlier this year,
I had this huge panic over serious allegations of,
uh, LGBT people claiming that they were marauding right-wing gangs,
driving around, trying to kill people with bats, with hammers,
trying to, uh, kidnapped them.
And these were all rumors that were reported on social media calls to huge
frenzy. Even the mayor, uh, had to come out and, you know,
issue statement about how he was concerned there was an emergency town hole with
the local career center. And, um,
so I started looking into all these allegations,
so it was 15 of them and I found that of the 15 only one was reported to police
and what was reported to police and documented in the report was entirely
different from the go fund me,
where over $10,000 was raised for this trans activists. Um,
she had alleged that one night walking home transphobic people had beat her with
a bat and knocked him unconscious.
Police report said that she was extremely intoxicated and likely fell and there
was no evidence that anybody had assaulted her.
So when this story came out because anti-fog was really antifa and the
democratic socialists of America and Portland were really involved in paddling
this hate crime fear in Portland. And I just Kinda, you know,
threw water on this, uh, uh, panic that they have been,
um, flaming. And so on the 1st of May,
um,
there was a riot that I was covering and one of the mast and seafood people went
up and sprayed me with, I think it was Bam Mace,
some type of chemical that blinds you and burns. You saw that video? Yeah.
So there was no police that ha that was there that,
I mean that Antifa event was publicly advertised on Facebook and all that.
So over and over,
like Antifa is very transparent about their calls for people to come to the
stuff and to engage in this physical confrontation that they call self defense.
And the police either stay away or on purpose or are told to stay away.
So
it's very confusing because when you watch the videos there,
there's amazing people. They're amazing people who disagree with them,
like they're yelling at each other.
And then someone will come along and makes people,
and for the police to not step in and do something, it's, I don't,
I don't think there's another city in the country that would allow something
like that. It just doesn't,
it doesn't seem like it makes any sense at all because you're,
you're not talking about people that are being physically attacked and that are
macing someone to protect themselves or even a threat of being physically
attacked.
They're just disagreeing with each other and yelling at each other and then
someone will come along and start macing people.
And I've seen it many times and I think there's also a real problem with people
wearing masks. You know, what, whether their ideology makes sense or not.
When you put people in masks and then you have a bunch of people yelling and
escalating and then there's teams, there's team antifa versus team, you know,
anybody opposing them they feel is a white supremacist or a Nazi.
And this is just how they've chosen to frame it, to dehumanize people.
And then you see them attack people.
I'm sure you're aware of the girl who got maced in the face because she had a
hat on that said make bitcoin great again,
but it was the same color hat as the make America great again hat and she got
maced in the face and she got hit with something too. Right.
Then she had hit in the face with something. Anyway,
this kind of shit is really weird.
It's really weird and disturbing to see these young people with these ideals,
idealistic versions of what they're doing.
I think a lot of the people that are involved in that really think they are
fighting fascism. They really do.
They really think that Donald Trump and the proud boys and white supremacists
from Charlottesville carrying Tiki torches,
that these people represent something horrible that sweeping across the country
in the young people today need to stand up and fight against this and they're
putting on masks and they're carrying backpacks and whacking people in the head
with crowbars is really fucking weird to see and it's really weird that the city
of Portland or all cities in fact haven't made some sort of a law where you
can't walk around in public with a fucking mask on because that is one of the
things that helps these people.
It's the same thing that you see on social media when people are anonymous and
they say the most horrible, hateful shit,
they're saying that because they're not in front of you,
you can't recognize them.
They don't have to take responsibility for what they're saying.
This is a lot of the same characteristics that a person has when they're wearing
a costume.
You're dressed in all black with gloves on and a face mask and you're hitting
people with a bike lock. Like what? What is that about? Well,
what that's about is you're getting away with being anonymous and you're getting
support from all these other people around you.
There's this mob mentality that takes place.
It's well documented with humans where when you get a group of people together
and there's another group and it's like, it's a tribal warfare type situation,
and that's what you're seeing within TIF.
And the fact that the Portland police have,
I don't know what's going on with them,
whether they've been told to not handle that,
but the fact they haven't done anything to mitigate this is fucking, uh, it's,
it's embarrassing. It's a shame. It's, it's terrible. It really is.
It's a term, it's a travesty.
You asked about the mayor earlier and, and if he issued any stand down orders,
there's a statement that was put out after I was attacked by the puddle Turner,
who's the president of the police union and he said very clearly,
he called from the male to remove the handcuffs,
handcuffs of law enforcement so they can enforce the law.
And he accused them out of politicizing the police department.
Is this mayor popular? No, he's not.
He's hated.
Well by moderates because of the things that he allows top in the city.
But the far left hate him as well. They view him as not radical enough.
Why, why are they mad at you? Is it just the articles that you've written?
Cause somebody told me that you had been accused of doxing people. Is that true?
Absolutely not true. So this is such an outrageous defamatory claims.
So what happened was, uh, on May Day at that riot,
there was one of the Antifa women, uh,
had charged in to participate in the fight during the rope brawl and one of the
right wing person, he was wearing a mouse. I didn't know who he was,
allegedly had uh, hit her on her head.
Nia had on her neck somewhere like that. She was knocked out.
I recognized this woman from her activism that day as the person who,
um, sabotage the sound equipment.
When James DiMauro came to Portland state in February of last year,
that was an event that I was involved in organizing, uh,
putting Portland State University.
And we should just explain to people, James DeMaurice,
the author of the Google memo that was talking about women in tech that was
wildly misrepresented what he had said and the people had claimed that he was
this awful sexist,
even the CEO of Youtube said that he enforced harmful gender stereotypes where
while he was citing, um,
evolutionary psychology and the citing all these different studies on why women
gravitate towards particular fields and even a page and a half encouraging a
strategy, do you track strategies to encourage more women to get into tech?
But it was basically in response to things that Google had written about dealing
with the lack of women in tech. What, what is the problem here?
They were looking for a PR for pro very particular answer, which was sexism.
And he was saying, well,
it actually has more to do with the choices that women sort of naturally tend to
gravitate towards.
And he was saying that there was a way to prob possibly encourage women to get
into technology and he divides these strategies to do so,
but was wildly misrepresented. And He, if you meet the guy,
and I've had him on the podcast, he is a soft spoken sweetheart of a guy.
He's not, I'm not a massage dentist, not a mean spirited person.
He was merely looking at the results of studies and he was looking at real raw
data and this real tendency that certain people have to gravitate towards
certain positions in life.
Yeah. So there was so many misconceptions about James somewhere, which is why,
uh, the student group I was involved in was invited him to come,
but Antifa and the allies just could not take that.
They tried to shut down the event. They tried to get it console.
And at that event, this one woman, she, uh,
damage to sound equipment as she was trying to shut it down,
she pulled all these quotes out and pushed the soundboard on the ground at
broke. So I recognized her from that day. She was named in the media. Um,
and then on May Day recognize her. So I named her, I said,
this is the name of the woman who was knocked out. I recognize her from, uh,
the James demoine event. Uh,
protest where she had done ministry equipment and Antifa had spun that around as
me doxing her. Um, that's not doxing.
Doxing is where you release people's personal details such as where they work,
where they live, their phone numbers with the,
so that people who identified her, I named her, yes,
but she had been identified in the media before. She was a big local activists.
So that's basically it. Other than you writing these stories,
criticizing their behavior,
what's disturbing to me beyond disturbing was legitimate journalists that were
making excuses for why you got beat up and people saying things like play stupid
games when stupid prizes. I saw stuff like that that pick a better hobby.
I saw a guy write that, you know, antifascists will rule.
No Portland's not your place.
I saw all this crazy shit from people that blue check marks that were saying
that this is what happens when you support fascism.
And I was so baffled by this. Like I read some of your stuff.
I haven't read all of it admittedly, but I've read some of you stuff.
None of it came off as you supporting fascism.
It came off as you maybe at the worst case scenario,
being a contrarian and not wanting to go with this sort of left wing ideology
that is so widespread throughout the Pacific northwest. But I didn't,
I didn't see any, I mean, first of all,
you're not a white guy. We should be explained to people.
You are Vietnamese and you know,
you're what they would consider a member of a protected class.
You're not just a minority, you're openly gay.
You mean your, your what? What do you consider yourself politically?
I've been avoiding labels for a while. I think,
and it's interesting that a lot of the coverage on what happened to me always
call the fide my Jay, um,
who I am as like conservative journalist.
Well, the worst thing is the way they're labeled Colette, they were said,
you work for far right? A Newspaper Magazine, Colette,
which is not the case at all. That's not true.
I think the subtle, I mean the dog was sorts of,
they're trying to say in there that this person deserved it.
And of course these are the same people who always talk about believes the
victim. They were the ones who jumped on to believe justice.
Marlette um, but uh, I guess I was the wrong type of victim.
Well exactly because even though you are, you're,
you seem like a very nice person. You aren't doing anything violent. You,
you supporting the wrong thing or not supporting them, not supporting,
not just blindly supporting what Antifa is involved with,
which is what I mean. That is what fascism is.
I mean you can't even question some of the more heinous things that make clearly
heinous things they're doing. Just fucking macing people in the audience,
Mason people in the crowd just pointing it at people yelling and screaming,
hitting each other with things. When you're wearing masks,
getting involved in these brawls, it's so fucking stupid.
It's so stupid to watch.
It's like this is base human behavior and its worst example and the fact that
this dumb ass fucking mayor thinks that this is a good idea to let this play
itself out. This is how people get shot.
This is how people die when you allow a certain amount of violence and when you
can,
don't or don't do anything with violence that you can't defend like violence
against a person like yourself.
I saw those guys hitting you in the back of the head,
throwing milkshakes at you where your truck just trying to walk away.
You weren't doing anything.
Yeah. You, you asked me after getting, how did I get the, the brain hemorrhage.
So the video that's gone viral out there,
there's actually the second half of the beating.
I don't know if there's video of the first half, hopefully, um,
there is through CCTV or something, but the first,
there are more hits to my face in my head.
And so when I went to the hospital, uh,
because of the nature of the contusions on my head, they did a CT scan in the,
um, in the Er and that confirmed the sub arachnoid hemorrhage.
So what started it?
What, what was the, why did you get hit? Okay. 29th of June.
Okay. Uh, that would be 10, 11 days ago from now.
And so there was that demonstration happening.
Antifa was rallying to oppose the fall. Right. They claim of pose fascists.
I came, I was excited to use my new GoPro. I was a bit nervous. Um, speaking,
I'm going to like van, I was nervous cause I had been targeted just um,
two months earlier. Right.
I left my house with the helmet and got in my car and saw briefly my,
you wear a helmet. I had to help let, I did have one.
I saw a reflection on myself, took it off,
decided I don't want anybody there to get the impression that I can't,
cause they already accused me of being a Nazi in fall rights and white
supremacists.
I didn't want any of them to then perceive me by the fact that I came to the
helmet as possibly a combatant. So I left that at home.
That means white supremacists is up possible in their always. Yes. Hilarious.
And, I mean this goes to the,
the bigger issue that I've taken issue with how flipping people use these
accusations of not just racist or being Nazi or far right,
but it's like what part of what makes anti-fossil dangerous is that they feel
that they are morally justified in the brutality. Yes.
And they get actually a lot of morale from progressive and left wing media.
So, um, after talking about what the attacker would like to talk about,
how the actual militant anti photos people is very small,
those who are going out and doing the violence,
the lodge or group and those that I find more concerning actually or the
nonviolent ENT feel antifa find those more concerning because they work to
mainstream anti phys tactics and ideas.
Like now doxing by Antifa is not even,
is kind of seen as well, these people deserve it.
I'm like,
do people not realize like when your docs and your peoples, you know,
releasing your addresses happened to me,
your family's address out it.
It puts this constant state of fear in you even when you're in your own home.
Like, I don't know if they realize that. Um,
so there's the doxing and then of course you know,
the punch or not see meme was meant to be cute and funny. Um,
but when they labeled such large segment of the population that's Nazi, it's,
it's, it's going after a lot of people who um,
are innocent and law abiding such as myself,
but they're also calling Jewish people Nazis is actually insane.
And then now more recently the, the milkshake and leucine us as cute,
nonviolent for my political dissent.
As you saw in the video after I was getting beaten,
I was trying to get away then they were pelting all liquids at my head and in my
face and that blinded me. I couldn't even see really which way to leave.
So to backtrack a little bit, sorry,
I'm jumping all over the march. It was right in the heart of downtown
justify as attack. They were chanting no hate, no fear. This is irony of it.
I remember that very clearly.
The crowd was chanting that I was walking towards the front of the
demonstration, thought I would to get a wide angle shot on my golf,
a GoPro before I could get there.
Somebody bashes me really hard in the back of the head and I've never been in a
fight. Um, Mr Rogan.
So I didn't even realize what had happened to me.
I was knocked forward as soon as I caught my footing,
the punches kept coming from every direction and all I could see was like,
um, people just in block with mass.
And most of them that were hitting me hard on these gloves that have the
hardened, um, knuckles,
I think it's like slap gloves or tactical clothes and it was just endless.
And I could see in the background like, um,
this was in front of the Justice Center. This is the other side irony.
So in broad daylight,
in the of downtown steps away from the central police precinct,
from the sheriff's office, this beating happened,
no police intervene at any point. I don't really see it. I don't know. I,
nobody came to my aid at any point before, during or after.
So this happens out of nowhere. You get side of the back of the head,
a bunch of people punch you. I mean, how many times do you think you got hit?
Maybe six or more.
The,
the fact that people dismissed this as not being a big deal is really horrific
to me. The fact that the people that are in Antifa that are nonviolent folks,
which I think I'm,
I'm glad you brought that up cause I was going to bring that up,
that it's the extreme of the extremists, right?
It's the people that think that there's a call for violence and that there's a
reason to do it. And even someone like yourself that is a nonviolent person.
I was just there as a journalist that there is a justification for just just for
whatever reason you want, just go up to that person and start hitting them.
Even though they're not a threat,
even though they're not doing anything to harm anybody,
even though they're not putting anybody in danger there,
they're just being a journalist and you feel like you could justify hitting
them. It's really disgusting. And it's this guy,
I mean there was this thing with vox where Carlos Mesa was
minimizing um, the,
the impact of Antifa and kind of joking around about it and making it seem like
it's just no big deal.
And he got really upset cause Steven Crowder was making fun of the fact that
he's gay.
And the fact that he talks with the list and that crowd or mentioned that along
with mocking his stance on Antifa and then it became this gigantic thing that
Steven Crowder's a gay basher.
But what didn't become a big deal is that this guy is minimizing violent
fascists. And that's what I mean. That's how I feel about this.
When you're trying to enforce your own ideology on other,
and you have no tolerance for anybody with a different opinion,
particularly journalists, that is fascism.
It's so ironic to call yourself an antifascist when you're literally in forcing
your own particular ideology to the point of violence and you're wearing masks
and you're running around hitting people and pretending that you're being
inundated with Nazis and white supremacists and that this is all necessary.
Like that old man that was just driving and they're directing traffic and
forcing him to obey them, and then when he doesn't watch it,
they chase after him and assault him. It's fucking bananas.
And the fact that this city has not stepped in and recognize that they have a
real problem because this has got momentum behind it and the people that are
involved that are nonviolent, you got to speak up. They've got to speak up.
If you're a person that really believes that there shouldn't be homophobia and
there shouldn't be violence and there shouldn't be white supremacy,
good for you. You probably got involved in this for all the right reasons.
But if you don't recognize that someone like you yourself who is a person of a
different ethnicity, you're not a white person. You're Vietnamese,
you're a gay man and you got assaulted for no reason.
You didn't do anything that mean.
It's almost like a test of where do your values truly lie and if you think it's
okay for a person like you to just get assaulted for no reason,
you are the problem. You're the problem.
Your mindset is the problem.
It's not whether or not there should be white supremacy.
Of course there shouldn't be.
It's not whether or not there shouldn't be people be able to freely express
themselves. Of course there should be.
That is not what the issue is with the issue is his group mob mentality.
When you get people together and you let them wear masks and you tell them that
they're fighting against some evil and then they feel justified and hitting a
person like you,
it is really sickening and there's this diffusion of responsibility thing that
happens when one person hits you and everybody feels like it's okay to hit you.
It's a mob mentality thing and it's, it is extremely common with human beings.
I've been in mob situations. It's terrifying because you feel it in the air.
You feel the chaos in the air when you're in some sort of a,
a large scale brawl type situation, like anything can happen.
People just run up on people and start punching them.
It's not like two people alone in a, in a,
in a like an open area where they can talk and work things out. No,
it's chaos and there's some weird animal activity.
There's some weird weird animal instinct aspect to it that is very unique to
humans and when you see something like this and see a guy like you just getting
peppered with milkshakes and punched in the head and it's fucking disturbing.
And for these people to dismiss that and not stand out, not stand up and say,
hey, this is not what we're supposed to be about.
This is not what I signed up for. They become a part of the problem.
I'm sure there's people listening to this that are upset at this because maybe
you, you, you've support Antifa you support their ideology.
Think about what you actually support.
Think about what this is really all about.
What you shouldn't be supporting is people wearing masks running around fucking
hitting people. You ain't changing shit with that.
All you're going to do is call for more people with masks from the other side.
If people feel like right-wing peep or being attacked.
And I don't think you're even right wing. Are you? I mean, what are,
what will you just, what would,
if you had a gun to your head or a mace to your face, what would you just say?
You're a centrist. What would you say?
I think it's fair to describe me on a center right. Center. Right. Okay.
Which is fine. It should be okay. I mean, there should be,
we should be allowed to have disagreements of ideologies and of political
persuasions, political, um, leanings.
But this is th it's twisted and it's twisted.
The way it's being depicted in the media.
It's very strange how it's being dismissed. It's very strange.
And that there's really people in 2019 debating whether or not it's okay to
assault journalists. It's fucking madness.
Well, we didn't seem to build up to this for years.
Pupil political violence coming from the left is seen as moral and unfortunately
even those working in mainstream media,
how that tynes excused or found that type of violence.
Good.
I'm thinking of Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon at CNN and I wonder if that played a
role in why they were the only center left, um, broadcast,
um, new station news network to invite me on to speak.
Um, no other leftist center media has invited me on, um, to anyway.
When they had you on the speak, what was their attitude about all this?
I think the host was very respectful and fair. Who else?
Who wasn't? Um, John Brennan? I think.
So. You think they were respectful and fair? Um,
did it bother you that people at Chris Cuomo and Don Limmud had openly supported
Antifa
it did it, I mean, this is,
was kind of encouraged me to continue to doing my work, um, months ago,
even last year when I was getting threatened because it seemed like,
I don't think Chris or dawn actually understood,
I think the ignorant about Antifa. I think you're right. You know,
they fall and they believe the, the propaganda about them.
That's just an antifascist movement. Yeah.
Well the name of [inaudible] itself,
I'm hoping that, like even with my injuries and some you can see some,
you, you can't. Um, I'm continuing to speak,
force myself to do all of these media engagements because I want the needle on
the conversations about Antifa to, to, to move to change.
Like this is not just a movement of people masking up and starting random
violence on the streets. Like the violence isn't just, it has not arbitrary.
It's working towards their goal. It's a movement of violent,
radical anarchists and communists and they're agitating for political revolution
in violence as part of the modus operandi. It's not a bug,
it's a feature of what they do.
So I don't know if people recognize how dangerous this is,
this movement and the DHS since 2016 has described some of antic fuzz activities
as domestic terrorist violence. So the fact that they're able to openly,
um, organize and recruit on social media is, it's a baffling to me.
I'm wondering like there's such this huge blind spot for far left melodies and
see, not shits in mainstream media but also in big tech.
Do you think this is because Trump is president and because so many people
oppose Trump as president did? The idea of far left militancy is in a,
in opposition to what they oppose so they feel like the the enemy of my enemy is
my friend. That's exactly what it is.
I think it what Eric Weinstein had a great point about this and he said the one
of the real issues is the cowards of the left and the cowards of the right that
are allowing the extremists to do the work for them.
So when people see someone like the proud boys running around attacking people,
even the proud boys, you have to realize that they started off as a joke.
Like when Gavin McInnes first came up with the idea of the proud boys, it was,
it was literally a joke and it became an actual organization at for fun.
And then people joined it that didn't think it was a joke.
And then people joined it and starting taking in a deeper and deeper direction.
Then he eventually disavowed himself in in a abandoned the group. You see the,
I bet. I bet you see the same thing with Antifa. I bet the idea initially was,
hey, we see these Tiki torch carrying assholes in Charlottesville.
We see that guy with the car ran over,
the girl who was a protester and killed her like this fucking shit has got it
stopped. So we have to organize, we have to do something and then what happens?
You get people in masks and you get people justified and then you get people
that support those people.
Then you get the extremists and the extremists who are not disavowed, who are,
who are not the, there's no one speaking out against them from the left.
There's no one saying, hey,
this shit has got to stop because they want them to do their dirty work for
them. They want them to push the envelope and push the agenda and get their
[inaudible], their ideology moving in the right direction.
Even if it's done through methods that they don't agree with and that's where it
gets horrible.
Because I see these people that are involved in this and I know for a fact just
by watching them move and interact with each other,
they don't understand violence. They don't, they're not good at it.
They don't understand it. This is like role play.
It's like caused play and you're going to call for real.
You're going to get real violence return and from people who actually know how
to do it. And if you look at violence from the left and violence for the right,
violence from the right scares me a whole lot more.
There are a lot more armed [inaudible].
There are more dangerous human beings in general. And I think that if this,
this keeps happening and people from the right feel threatened and their
lifestyle feels threatened and their ideologies feel threatened,
you're going to get people meeting at these things and it's going to be more
than just people throwing mace and milkshakes at each other.
It's going to be people showing up ready for actual combat.
That's fucking terrifying. It's fucking terrifying.
And this idea that you could just run around hitting people and not have any
consequences. It's just like the way a child looks at violence.
This is what bothers me so much. If you are,
if you looked at their core tenants of what they want to do and if they wanted
to accomplish that through political negotiation and through conversation and
rallies and speeches, fine, that's fine,
but when you have people wearing masks, hitting and macing people, you've,
you've pat,
you've crossed the line into the land of no return and you've called out to
people who oppose you.
You challenged them to come and do the same and this is how violence begets
greater violence. It's fucking dangerous. It's really dangerous.
Violence does not exist in a vacuum.
You can't just have a little bit of violence and then there's no repercussions.
People react to that.
There's people that watch those videos and watch you get punched and there is no
justification for that. When you see someone like yourself who's a small person,
slight in stature, not violent in any way, and you're,
you're not even swinging back,
you're just taking it and try to protect yourself.
People get infuriated by that. And there's people right now,
I guarantee you who saw that video,
who are thinking what I would do if I was there, I'd fucking shoot all of them.
Or I'd beat them all to death with baseball bats or I'd run him over with my car
or I do things. And the unhinged amongst the right who feel like this is, uh,
in opposition of their ideology,
they're going to show up some debt and when that happens,
people are going to die. This is a fucking terrible,
and this is where the mayor and the police and they have not done their job.
And I believe the police,
when they say that they've been handcuffed and maybe the mayor just didn't have
an idea of where this was all go, but now you do.
This is the mayor has been in office now for three years and he finally did a
press conference two days ago,
nine days after my talk to address this controversy. Right.
And what was so frustrating is that the,
the police chief had, um,
publicly stated that she thinks the city or the state should adopt a law that
makes it illegal to wear a mask while committing a crime.
That should be a no brainer. It's shocking that in Portland a
better idea. How about no,
you can't wear a mask in public at these events cause you can say you can't wear
a mask while committing a crime. You're wearing a mask. How do you,
who the fuck do you know committed the crime? You,
unless you take the mask off than you can't even identify them. It's stupid.
Do you can't wear a mask.
Yeah. So this, you know, it sounds like a baseline. Somebody,
a policy that you should start advocating for, right? Like don't kick babies.
Yeah. Well the mayor said he hasn't decided if he's supported it.
He hasn't decided if it supported whether it should be illegal to wear a mask.
While you're committing a crime. Right. That's hilarious.
And he had no policy proposals and he spoke as if, uh,
like it was his first day in office when this was like,
this is becoming routine now it's almost, but now in Portland and Portland is a,
is a harbinger and, and wanting to,
what can happen in other cities when you have a,
a
governant those in the upper echelons of governance,
turning a blind eye too far left militancy and just letting
these dogs go on the street.
Just imagine if that was the case. If they were doing that,
it'll be all about fall, right? Militancy.
Imagine if there were far right people who,
who were doing this and committing violence and the government was just like,
well, you know,
I'm not sure if they shouldn't be allowed to wear masks while they commit
crimes. People would be freaking the fuck out.
It's the weird justification of this stuff that's, that's so disturbing.
I just don't, and I fucking love Portland. It's one of my favorite places.
It's great. The city's great. I mean, it's fucking cool people.
It's not all of them that are involved in this is a very small number and the,
even amongst the small number,
it's the very small number of them that are radical, that are violent.
When you look at the people that are attacking you, not to minimize it,
but it's very few. You look at that video,
it's a couple people out of thousands of people that are in that group.
There's a few people that are attacking is about a dozen. Was it really?
Okay if you count throwing milkshakes but actually hitting you,
how many people you think hit you? I'm not sure. Three, four, maybe.
Something like that. Okay. That's the problem.
The problem is these fucking assholes.
It's not the people that disagree with you.
It's the people that think you should be able to throw milkshakes at people and
guys like Carlos Mesa who don't think it's a big deal.
Throw milkshakes at people. It's a fucking big deal. It's a big deal.
Cause you April, it calls her a response.
This is why it's a big deal and people don't understand assault.
They don't understand violence. You can't just do that. You, you,
you live in some comic book world or some fucking Disney show world where you
can just throw a milkshake at someone, they don't do anything.
They're going to turn around and punch you in your fucking face.
And then what happens? Well,
you might fall and hit your head and die because that's real.
That's the real world we live in.
Or you might cause a giant brawl cause people don't want to be hit with
milkshakes or there's enough of you where you think you can get away with it.
So you are an awful bully and you throw in milkshakes at someone because you
don't like what they stand for and you're meeting in a public place and you're
disagreeing about something. So to write this disagreement,
you're assaulting people.
Well for that very reason. Ante Fund
never engages in like a quote unquote fair fight one on one. They, uh,
what they do usually as a group while mast up one or several of them will
distract the person either by speaking to them perhaps or blinding them with a
chemical spray. And then they take tons, the beatings.
So there's even no opportunity to like no.
You know, you don't even know how many people hitting you at that point.
So that's what they do. Blind you and then a top. Hmm. Itself.
It's so scary because it's so dumb.
It's not just scared because like you watching what happened to you was scary.
Cause you know,
and watching that old man who got hit in the head with a crowbar,
it's fucking horrific. All that stuff's terrific.
And apparently that guy had pulled out some sort of a rod and was swinging at
people before he got hit with a crowbar. I do not know.
But I do know when you start hitting people in the head with Crowbars,
that is the beginning of the end. Horrible,
horrible shit happens in response to that. And it hasn't yet.
But this is 10 days ago.
Who knows what's going to happen if there's another one of these rallies and you
get people from the far right who organized this is when the proud boys really
radicalized. They radicalized to go against MTV. They were attacked,
they attacked them and then it became this fucking shit show that you're seeing
right now.
Yeah. I want to state for the record though, the,
the violence that happened after I was beat up was involving the,
the men's rights activists group and Antifa proud boys was holding a,
they held this operate event and in different parts of the city,
a as far as I know, they did not,
there was no conflict with this in this particular,
but in the Sewickley who was the men's rights guy? It was actually a woman,
a woman who's a men's rights person. Yes. That's hilarious. She must love Dick.
Right? If you had to guess,
no comment. Sorry, I'm a comedian. I couldn't help it. Um,
you don't even have to say her name. So she's, she, she organized this thing.
Yeah, I would say. Um, here's the other thing, you know,
like I might, what needs to be stated as well about,
I guess the right wing movements that, um,
are in Portland or come to Portland to do these events.
There's an element of being a provocateur as well,
but that should never ever justify the violence. Cause I mean w w
explain what you mean by being a provocateur.
Well, for example, holding uh,
an event in the middle of downtown titling it, um,
like any event,
justice for victims of domestic terrorism and then having a picture of Antifa
like that is an, you know, it's an flavor train. It's an infant,
you know, it causes a reaction. Um, so there's a,
you know, there's a,
there's an element of coming in and seeing let's enrage these lunatics on the
far left or whatever. But at the same time,
I want to make sure I state that just because somebody is quote unquote
provocative your tools in their words with a writing,
that it's unfortunate that people now find that that's justification for you to
react violently.
Well, I think again,
it's a small percentage of people that find that this justification and you look
at the number of people that were there, what does it thousands,
thousands of people, how many people actually engage in violence?
Small number but small number. That's the problem.
It's important to note that they caught morale from the crowd who were cheering
them on.
The cowards, the cowards who don't disavow this horrific action.
They cheered them on, laughed and clapped as I was getting beaten.
And then the other thing about the people showing up in numbers who don't engage
in the violence is they PR. They are like literal human shields.
They dress the same.
So they make it easy for the few violent militants to [inaudible] back into the
crowd. Exactly.
And these people also watched the cops and they keep an eye out on potential
outsiders as well. And yeah,
become a game. It's become a game has become a gigantic team war.
There's our team versus their team. It's,
it's literally like playing a child hood game.
It's really disturbing then. And so since this,
has anyone from antifa apologized about what happened to you or disavowed the
actions of these few extreme violent people?
Of course not.
I'm Antifa has an iron fist on the people who support its movements.
They don't allow any type of design actually in there. Like press releases,
you can call, call them. Um,
they explicitly state that even basically,
even if you disagree with their tactics, you will not publicly state it.
It's to create, I guess this image of unity, right, for a quote unquote in,
if you disagree inside the organization. Yes. So how organized are they?
They are a leader.
They're intentionally anti Phi as we understand it today,
really crystallize only after 2016 there's been very little academic research
until how they actually organize. But basically as a movement,
they have essentially cells across the country that are semi autonomous United
by an ideology of Aki and Arco,
communism and is support for violence.
So it's not so much a group itself,
it's the people who are part of that movement are drawn from other actual groups
who draw from the DSA. They draw from various workers, unions,
other anarchist groups and like other terrorists entities,
they have PR processes to radicalize, um,
sympathizers. Essentially. They have their own literature as well.
And so it's much more organized than people give them credit for.
They think of them as just, Oh, you know,
people showing up to fight on the street. It's, there's,
there's meaning to that,
to that violence and there's literature to back it up and they have PR,
you know, they actively recruit people to join the movement. So,
um, I've been asked like,
do you think the federal authorities should stopped in? And my responses,
I think it's come to the point that they do because with Antifa, um, it's not,
it's beyond what local authorities can do because a lot of these people,
a lot of them are in Portland from Portland, but a lot of them come from,
for example, from Eugene, from Seattle,
from neighboring areas that have other antifa people come in to participate in
the violence for that day or to help out.
And then they go back to where they're from. So they're,
they're coming in and out of jurisdictions. Makes it hard for one local body of,
of authorities to address it. I think, um,
the Goj needs to stop then. I think it's gotten to that point and with 20,
20 coming up soon, um,
there could be potential for a lot more political violence if the results don't,
if the elections results don't go as they wish.
Well, that's a, an obvious one.
Considering the fact that this all became a thing after Trump was elected. Yes.
Um, with the, if the DOJ did step in, what do you think they could do?
So that's, well,
I mean, do you believe in the,
the ability to meet up and express yourself publicly and the ability to protest
and the ability to just, uh,
get together and have groups and, and you know, express yourself?
Yes. However, that's not just what Antifa does.
Like I said, the violence is a feature of their movement.
So what federal authorities can do
stop you there. When you say the violence is a feature of your,
their movement is there, is it, did they have anything written,
like the tenants or their movement where they say that violence is acceptable?
There's a book called the antifascist handbook is written by Mark Bray.
He's an academic at doc myth. He is,
I would call him one of ANTIFA chief ideologues.
So not only does he explain what Antifa does and in his writing,
he's makes it very clear that the, um,
the quote unquote self-defense is what justifies the offensive violence.
He actually argues why that's ethical.
So because he's an academic, um, well spoken,
um, he's invited onto mainstream media to explain to basically, like I said,
early mainstream Antifa
what, can you explain what he says?
Yes. I highly recommend that. Take a look at his book. Um,
the attorney general in Minnesota, um,
Keith Ellison was photographed a year ago holding, holding up that book of, uh,
the Antifa book and that kind of went, um,
he's been criticized a bit for that and he deleted that and then shopped it
might be eating. Was holding it up in support. Yeah. He said this, he said, uh,
something about like this book or Antifa strikes fear into the heart of Donald
Trump. Yeah.
So there's people in government who has sympathetic to,
and this professor can explain what he says.
He outlines and explains essentially why Auntie's fuzz violence is ethical.
That it's because they're opposing fascism and fascism is a violent movement.
This is sort of a preemptive move. Like we have this word fascism. Yeah.
It is a problem, right? Yes.
Cause it seems like that's definitely something you should oppose.
But what is the, what's the actual definition of fascism?
Fascism as a fall, right.
Political ideology from what I understand is the definition,
Jamie, so we can just read what fascism,
what the actual word fascism means.
Heir form of radical right wing authoritarian, authoritarian,
ultra nationalism characterized by dictatorial power,
forcible suppression of opposition and strong regimentation of society and of
the economy which came to prominence in early 20th century Europe.
Um, forcible suppression of a, put the back up please.
Forcible suppression of opposition is what they're doing. Yes.
Strong regimentation of society. I mean they're,
they're literally telling people how to behave and what they will tolerate.
I know it's not right wing ideology,
but it's almost like fascism and I'm sure there's other definitions of fascism.
The idea of supporting someone who opposes fascism sounds wonderful.
Sounds great. Let's, let's stop fascism.
But are we really experiencing authoritarian ultra nationalism characterized by
dictatorial power in this country? I mean, is that, is that a fair thing to say?
I know people don't like Donald Trump.
I know people don't like right wing ideologies running this country.
I understand that. But this is not, this is not what's happening.
Yeah.
The issue like fascism as defined by political theorists who have been
researching this for decades,
it has a particular definition and meaning and that's, um,
I think that summarizes it pretty well.
I'm very concerned that people use it so flippantly to just refer to the right
or to even authoritarianism.
Like there's much more to it than just being authoritarian.
There's all the other components. And I need it is,
it's important to the state that Antifa is not just supposed to the far right or
the right. They're also against liberal democracy.
There's a reason why they hate the police on much hate border enforcement and
hate the rule of law.
It's there against died the concept of the nation state as we understand it and
they're working to dismantle that, to delegitimize it. So, um,
this is what I mean when I say it's a, it's a dangerous ideology that for now,
you know, enemy and my underneath is your, um, is your friend.
But at some point, if this movement becomes bigger,
more mainstream and more people are sympathetic,
at some point it's going to come back against the moderate left because these
people, um, they want to see the,
the destruction of the nation.
They'd want to see the destruction of the nation state for what purpose?
They want anarchy. Yes. So there are political antivirus, antiques,
social anarchists state. They don't want borders. They don't want nations.
They don't want police. Okay. What do they want?
B? I mean, what do they expect?
What's the ultimate goal? They seem to believe in
a utopian, utopian mocks.
This ideas right of this restrict free distribution of wealth where we can be,
we can only be truly equal and egalitarian when we dismantle everything about
the country. So not just, you know, it's institutions of rule of law,
but the state itself, like everything just has to be broken down and start over.
Cause it's irredeemable. I'm not quite sure if, I mean they've, um,
you know, Antifa um,
I can't think of like where they have had,
if there was any somewhat comparable examples around the world of what it looks
like for them to, um, do state building. Right.
So we don't know what it would actually look like, but I mean,
the examples we see from these smaller anecdotes is it's chaos and anarchy,
like absolute chaos and, um,
violent suppression of opposing views, um,
indiscriminate violence at times. Um,
I wonder,
and what I've been asking over and over is how many more people have to be drawn
into,
have to be victims of this violence before something changes.
And I put in Portland,
now we've had three years with us and literally no policy changes have happened.
No. Even proposals have even been accepted by the man.
The previous mayor was, what was his political persuasion or her,
I don't even know.
These are all the people who've become the elected mayor in Portland's are
typically establishment Democrats, right?
So they themselves are moderate, very much. Uh, you know,
in the vein of I'm a Hillary Clinton type of thing.
But does the constituent we'll see in Portland that they have to play two,
four votes, which is the
radical people who are sympathetic to very,
very progressive causes.
And so there's a reason why to date the mayor has never named Antifa one time in
any of his press conferences. He has no problem blaming prop boys,
a patriot para the right four issues, patriot prayer. What's that?
Then another group, Patriot prayers, one of the other right wing movements in,
uh,
in and around Portland that have held pro Trump events in town that antifa comes
to to fight and oppose and how those turnout,
they devolve until riots and the police allowed us,
they allow it through then auction. Wow.
It's just,
it's interesting to see a city that's gone so far off the rails like Portland in
this regard with this issue. Yeah.
When you see this inaction and what the consequences are and how,
how it happens and was particularly for Personal IQ, you physically see it,
you personally see it. Um, are you going to continue to do these things?
Okay.
Because it seems like you're obviously a target. Oh yeah. Um,
when I was asked this, uh, in my interviews this week, last week,
the, the, the response that I,
that comes to my mind right away is of course I'm going to continue doing it. I,
these people threatened me before I'd been a talked before.
I'm not going to be cowed, I'm going to continue, I won't be intimidated.
But with the, the brain injury that they gave me,
it's like I can't continue doing it the same way as I did before.
And being naive to think that police would actually uphold the rule of law.
Um, they gave me a brain injury and like I never had one before,
but I'm dealing with some cognitive and neurological issues or I will memory
issues, I have issues. So I have upcoming physical,
neuro physical therapy as well as speech therapy. So, um,
as much as like on the surface I have improved a lot since the beating.
There are some longterm consequences and I'm going to have to work through and
um, you know, I have to be honest,
I have certain fears and anxieties of being in Portland.
I've continued receipt threats, violent threats,
and they've been reported to police and just people promising to make sure next
time that I won't even be able to walk away,
that they will repeat what happens mean when they see me on the streets.
So like have they caught the people that did this to you?
So it's been 10 days now, more than 10 days since my beating.
There have been no arrests.
I don't know where the police are in the investigation.
They haven't been keeping me informed.
There was a photograph of someone they released. Yeah.
So the Portland police released photos of potential suspects and asking for help
in identifying, one was on mouse, two, two of them were a mouse and a,
I forgot to say earlier that in addition to the, the beating the robs me of my,
my camera equipment. So that was my,
my evidence for that day and I tried so hard to hold onto it, but, um,
I couldn't.
What about you attending this with security? Have you thought about doing that?
Yeah.
So moving forward once I feel well enough and once I'm cleared by the doctors,
um, it may be worth it to cover these events.
But with professional security, um,
gorillas. Yeah. Big giant dudes. Yeah.
Would they wear what black armor? Like what would you have?
How far would you take this?
I Dunno. W how far do you think I should take it?
I don't think you should go to those things anymore. Okay.
I mean it seems like you've been, I mean, it is part of your job,
you're a journalist,
but it seems like you've been singled out and targeted and it seems like they
don't have any problem justifying attacking you and assaulting you. Uh,
if I was going to go, I'd bring the biggest,
baddest dudes that I could find and a bunch of them and have them surround you
and have them protect you. What's that telling you about America?
That in 2019 tobacco it's this one particular area and this one particular group
and not even the group. I think it's the most ridiculous people in that group.
I don't think it's most,
I think most of these people that probably are a part of this really don't want
fascists and they really don't want some awful right ring totalitarian regime
running this country and in marginalized people of Color,
gay people and immigrants and all those things that I support 100% I'm left
wing. I mean, I would be on their side ideologically about a lot of things.
It's the implementation of it that I have the biggest problem with.
It's the group mentality. It's the wearing the masks, the salts,
so not understanding the consequences of violence, all these things.
This is what I have a problem with.
The way the the mayor allows us to take place, the way handcuffs the police,
that that is what I have a problem with.
It's not that they don't want horrible people running the government and running
the world. I understand that. That makes sense,
but you're not for the dismantling of the nation state, right? Nope. No, no.
I'm not. Or the breakdown on democracy. No. Yeah,
so these are the points that I'm trying to hit on.
Those are the points that are hidden, right?
These are important things that make up the ideology, events if a and the,
the larger, uh,
those who are sympathetic because of the antifascist aspect of the anti
right-wing, they are ignorant of it. And I hope to become more aware of that.
I think that's what's important about your work.
That's what's important about these discussions. That's,
it's important about people getting the word,
understanding what this really means, not what it seems on paper.
It's like where the Anti Nazi movement, Whoa.
Who the fuck could go against that? Of course your anti Nazi.
That's no who everybody should be. That's what it seems like. What we're,
we're antifascist good. We don't want fascists.
I think that's what Chris Cuomo was saying.
I think that's what Don Lemon was saying. I think they're too busy.
I don't think they're really investigating this.
I don't think they're deep diving and understanding the ideology at it's core,
the way you're describing it. And um,
whoever that professor was that you were discussing that is, uh,
somehow or another condoning violence,
that that is ridiculous.
Anyone who considers themselves an intellectual who condones violence,
all this punch and Nazi stuff, goddammit, you don't understand violence.
You don't know what you're talking about.
You don't understand the human condition because if you,
if you understood violence, it's the last thing you would ever be calling for.
Can I talk about the, um, the next step of what's next? For sure.
So a lot of people listening in are frustrated and have expressed support,
are asking, well, what can I do?
I'm just one person and this is the power. Now we,
we live in a time where there's crowd funding and you know,
with all the points that we brought up earlier,
it seems to show a lot of evidence to suggest that there's something seriously
wrong in up echelons of policing and governing in Portland.
And that's what the, the legal fund is. So, um, I'm working with, um, how neat.
Dylan, she represented Jane's De Moore. Um,
she's taken a neon is the first client for the nonprofit that she started
called. Um, if you go to Publius, lax, P U B, l, I,
U s l e x.com, you'll see, um,
information for how you can donate and anything helps. And we're trying,
we, you know, lawsuits if they happen against, um,
the city or a mayor or police department costs a lot of money and takes a lot of
time, takes, you know,
there's a lot of overhead costs in the amount of people you know,
you have to take in to do all the investing, um, to do your investigations.
So there's an opportunity for the public to get involved. Um, you know,
I don't want the story to pass just about Andy, you got beat up. So what,
let's move on.
But rather there's systemic issues happening in Portland and there are
implications for the rest of the country.
What do you think is going on with media that is supporting this attack on you?
Because I,
I've seen so many journalists dismiss this as being not a big deal.
Why?
Why do you think that anybody would look at something like that or someone's
being beaten publicly and not think it's a big deal?
What do you think is behind that?
Okay.
Extremist ideologies are very good at dehumanizing the opposition and that's
what Antifa does.
So there has been a lot of disinformation as information put out about me.
You know, I'm not, I'm not, they say for example, I'm not really journalists,
I'm just a far right, provocative. I'm somebody who's sympathetic to Nazis.
Um, and so when you put these ideas out that not only are lies,
but I meant to
remove one's humanity, they just become, you know,
like Andy's no longer Andy.
Andy is to face of far-right ideology and it makes people feel comfortable.
What's violence against that?
And it was so disheartening to see so many writers come out and say things like,
you know, I don't really support what happened to Andy, but he's done far worse.
Or he was provocative here. His writings,
like he came and he got exactly what he was looking for.
What happened to me should happen to nobody, um,
much less to journalists. Right? I'm like,
this is an America in a major American city. We're not, you know,
this is not enough guidestone or Iraq where the state is weak.
We have a strong state, we have police force.
Why are the laws not being enforced? Why is such a sons having to suffer, uh,
arrest? Why are they no arrests?
It's really absurd and it's obscene. Yeah.
Um,
okay.
When is the next one of these things supposed to take place
on the 17th of August is supposedly the next event.
I think the proud boys have announced that they're encouraging all of their
members across the country to,
to fly into Portland and it's always fucking Portland. Yeah.
They're kind of reacting I think to the 29th of June. So,
um,
we'll see what happens. I'm concerned. Are you going to grow up?
I don't know.
You should go and get a pope mobile. Yeah.
Let 'em throw milkshakes at the Pope Mobile. Get a big old fish tank.
Put some wheels on it. Have some giant dude to push around the,
I'm joking around about it obviously to try and make light,
but do you really think you're going to go?
I don't know if I feel safe and I hate you shouldn't feel safe.
While I hate using the language of the identitarian left, you know,
like I feel unsafe and all that. I'm trying to remain rational. Okay.
But you were assaulted twice and I continue to receive threats.
You were assaulted
what? In May? Yes. And then you were assaulted again in June. Yeah. Yeah.
So, and you can see continued to receive threats.
Um, is this necessary to go to these things? To cover them.
Okay.
Do you think maybe that's part of the problem with people that like Don Lemon
and Chris Cuomo who are talking about this, who haven't actually been there,
they really don't understand it.
And maybe you do because you're covering it with boots on the ground.
You got it. You know,
when you're all the way in New York City and you work for elite media and you
always, even when you traveled to protest,
you have a very large crew of security around you.
It does, it removes you a bit from the reality of the situation.
And I don't think any of these people who are opining on these mainstream media
television shows have actually embedded themselves to covering these violent
riots that are happening in Portland or in Berkeley.
Okay.
Um, how many of the people that are involved in Antifa do you think really
understand that they're trying to dismantle the government,
really understand that they want the state to absolve, dissolve?
I don't have a number for that. It's definitely small.
It's the same people who engage.
It would probably be around those who are engaging in violence and those who are
eating and that violence, for example, creating shields or whatever,
allowing them to hide among them.
Those people I think understand very much what the ideology is.
Those people who come unmasked, you know, and just read the,
the Facebook event page, oppose fascists, come protect Portland.
Those people I think are ignorant of the ideology behind the movement and groups
that are organizing these events. Um,
I can't put a number on that and this is like where there needs to be a research
by academics and um, and think tanks to look into. Um,
and this is where federal authorities need to be looking into as well.
Like how are they organized?
Where are the businesses that are helping them fund some of their causes?
Cause they, you know, when some of them member members get arrested,
they have money for bail. Who's involved in funneling that money on,
uh, who's helping to,
to disperse the literature that they use to radicalize people like these are,
this requires research and intelligence gathering. And as far as I know,
it's not being done.
There's a real concern among some people that we're entering a phase of this
country where it,
there's a real possibility of having some sort of a civil unrest,
civil war.
When you see something like these Portland events,
when you see this kind of chaos,
do you think that that's a valid concern?
Okay.
Not for something that is across the country,
but perhaps very regional or to the city itself and not so much like civil war,
but the violence that is done plan by Antifa.
It's meant to make the wider public,
not just polarize and hate each other,
but also began to distrust than to institutions that are in place.
I meant to uphold democracy.
So the police in Portland have come under fire, for example,
not just from the radical left,
but a lot of people who are normally very pro police are finding like what is
wrong with them pulling police? Like we can't even trust them. So there's um,
if things just continue,
I think the violence would continue to escalate leading to a death or death.
Um, that's my real concern. Um,
this is my real concern as well.
And you think this is particularly unique to Portland in the way that they're
treating it and addressing it?
I'm trying to think of comparable other cities that have had some of these
issues. So for example, in San Jose in 20s,
16 Trump supporters when they were leaving a Trump rally were brutally assaulted
by mobs of people.
And then there was a lawsuit that was launched against the city for basically
putting citizens in the way of danger.
The way they were funneled outside of this event,
led them directly in front of these violent protesters who had talked them,
you know, in those footage that, um,
went viral that that year since then,
policing tactics have changed in San Jose as far as I know,
and you know, involved the lawsuit.
So like sometimes it takes lawsuits for the local government to start protecting
people's civil rights. So right now, as bad as it is,
it does seem confined to Portland. We haven't seen that. For example,
in Berkeley, the type of, uh, violence as, um,
in 2017 when Milo came, like, you know, that hasn't been repeated, uh,
uh, for a year and a half now. So, um,
but it takes the political will of those in power to enforce the law.
All right. So you mentioned lawsuits. What lawsuits are you pursuing?
Well, immediately,
right now what I would like to see is the city or Portland carry out a full
investigation and hold accountable.
All those who involved in attacking me or aided in that as well.
And then as the evidence where the evidence leaves,
if this shows that there were was dereliction of duty from those in power,
then you know, I reserve my judgment and my lawyer reserves judgment for,
you know, uh, who, if anyone gets sued at that point.
But right now I'm very focused on that,
putting pressure on the city to arrest people who are responsible in charged on,
in kept convictions as well.
All right. And in closing, cause I know you got to get out of here.
Is there a silver lining to any of this? I mean,
do you think that perhaps your assault and the fact that the police didn't
intervene is actually allowing people to understand the,
the real significance of this, the real problem of this, that it's,
this is a real issue,
a gigantic one in fact that goes against the core tenants of value of free
expression and the ability to gather and communicate safely in public?
Yeah,
as hard as it was for me to see a silver lining when I was laying in hospital
with so much pain. Um,
there is one and that is that everybody paid attention to what happened to me.
It was a big story. Even the mainstream liberal press cannot ignore it.
And I'm hoping that from that it goes beyond just being a headline but forcing
the national discourse to change on how it views and talks about Antifa we'll
see if that happens.
I feel encouraged that we're beginning to see some cracks in the way that Antifa
has been protected by sympathetic writers in journalists in those,
in mainstream media.
I mean the fact that Keith Ellison deleted that photo that he showed a year ago,
um, right after that was attacked I think indicates that did even,
he faces a certain impression of that.
It may not be good for a mainstream politician to so actively promote this
movement. Um,
and I hope it continues to move in that direction.
If you had a crystal ball and you were looking at the future, what do you,
what do you think you'd see?
Well, based on the press release,
a press conference at the mayor did two days ago in a not sure not having any
proposals. Um, it seems like more violence has to happen.
All right, Andy, I hope you Brung me too, but, uh, thank you for being here.
My pleasure. All right. Take it easy. Thank you. Stay safe out there with you.
Thank you. Smile too.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].